welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching thank you for listening hope
you've had a great morning so far I want
to I don't mean to disturb you but I
want to start with two stories there's
sort of harrowing stories that I want to
tell just just to start with because it
relates to the subject at hand so here's
the first story these are both true
stories by the way last week I went into
a cafe in DC and I really needed to use
the bathroom so I went in and I said
where's your bathroom
and they said bathrooms are for
customers only and so clearly the next
thing that I did was I called the FBI
for because it was a hate crime I mean
what how also you're supposed to how
else can you respond to something like
that no actually what I did was I I said
oh okay and then I bought a coffee and
then I said can you hold the coffee here
for a minute
I'm gonna use the bathroom because it's
it's actually the concept of a
restaurant or a store only allowing
customers to use the facilities that's a
really normal concept in the world that
I live in which is just reality where a
great many stores and restaurants have
that policy now here's the second story
again totally a true story this didn't
happen to me but I did witness it and I
was traumatized by it I was at a
Starbucks a few months ago and I was
sitting there doing my work money
minding my own business there was a guy
it wasn't even that busy by the way but
there was a guy at a table few tables
over from me and he was I noticed he was
just sitting there at the table for a
little bit it wasn't drinking any coffee
didn't buy anything and they falls
asleep and he's like sleeping at the
table for only a couple of minutes and
until the manager comes over and wakes
him up and says you're gonna have to
leave you can't sleep here and so the
guy packs up his stuff and leaves
there's a white guy by the way
again you know I didn't even realize it
at the time but but apparently I
witnessed a horrible human rights
infringement because this guy had a
human right to come into private
property and use it as a you know a
camping ground if he wanted to now I
tell these stories because they were
late to the obviously the Starbucks
controversy which has been raging and
still hasn't calmed down over the last
few days and the latest on that let me
see if I could find out just looking at
the story The Daily wire has the story
that on Tuesday Starbucks announced that
the company is going to close over 8,000
stores across the United States next
month to conduct racial bias education
geared toward preventing discrimination
in their stores so that's approximately
175,000 Starbucks employees who now will
have to undergo racial bias or you know
discrimination training because of these
two incidents that happened at two
different Starbucks locations over the
last few days if you're not familiar
just very quickly I'll get you up to
speed there have been protests and
boycotts and everything because of these
two incidents the first incident
happened in a Starbucks in Philadelphia
a video surfaced and went viral of two
black men being escorted out of a
Starbucks in cuffs they were being
arrested in handcuffs it's a you know
pretty short video and there's not a lot
to it there's not you know we don't see
what happened before then or after we
just see these guys being escorted out
not a lot of details but just the image
of two black men being arrested and
removed from a Starbucks that was enough
in the minds of a lot of people the
minds of the pitchfork pitchfork mob
especially that was enough to prove that
well clearly there's racism here I mean
there couldn't possibly be any other
explanation at all it must be racism
because these two guys were black then
so that was that was a that
was enough of a controversy and then on
Monday I don't know if it was on Monday
but yeah it was on Monday a Starbucks in
Los Angeles went viral because there was
video shot by a black man who went into
this Starbucks asked to use the restroom
and they said well restrooms are for
customers only
now again very normal policy especially
especially now maybe if you live in a
more rural area if you live in the
suburbs maybe you don't encounter it as
much but at urban restaurants and stores
where there are a lot of people coming
in and out this is extremely common in
fact it's the norm it's I I can't
remember the last time I went into a you
know a restaurant in a city and they
would just let anyone use the bathroom
even if they weren't customers so really
normal policy this guy he couldn't
responded the way that I did when I was
in DC and I was told the same thing and
that is just buy something buy a coffee
buy a you know just buy a buy a cup of
yogurt I mean buy anything and then you
can use the restroom but that's not what
this guy does
instead he pulls out of his camera and
he pulls out his phone and he starts
taking video then a white guy walks out
of the restroom and without asking by
the way you know this the the black guy
comes up to the white guy puts him on
camera doesn't ask his permission and he
finds out that the white guy apparently
hadn't bought anything either
yet he was allowed to use the bathroom
so that proves racism then he goes up to
the manager who by the way does not
appear to be white herself she's a woman
appears to be not sure what her race is
but she appears to be a non white woman
and he starts berating her for her
supposed racial bias and in both cases
that's enough for the pitchfork mob and
so now you know Starbucks is in is in
cleanup mode the Starbucks CEO just
absolutely threw his own employees under
the bus this the manager at the
Philadelphia location he just
through who we're under the bus didn't
even try to defend her and now he's been
he met with the mayor of Philadelphia
he's met with you know activists he met
with the two men who were arrested
he's been guilty he was like Good
Morning America I mean he's been meeting
with it he met with he met with I think
he met with the king of Saudi Arabia as
well for some reason he's just meeting
with everybody talking about this and
just throwing his employees under the
bus in the process and even this racial
bias discrimination training you're
essentially throwing your employees
under the bus again what you're implying
I mean if you're forcing 175,000
employees to undergo this bias training
what you're insinuating is that a lot of
them are racially biased now here's the
thing
a couple things first of all I'm not a
fan of Starbucks policy I do like their
product I'll admit I know a lot of
people don't they say it tastes burnt
but I guess I like burnt coffee so I
like their burnt coffee not a fan of
their politics so I'm not one to usually
defend Starbucks but even less am i a
fan of pitchfork mobs and I know that
sometimes conservatives will tend to
when they see something like this they
see the liberal pitchfork mob coming
after a liberal company the
Conservatives will sit back and say oh
isn't this nice isn't this nice to watch
this happens see there being being
hosted with their own petard that's a
that's a nice thing to see well I think
it's a really bad idea I've said this
many times it's a bad idea to take the
side of the pitchfork mob in any
situation no matter who they're coming
after I mean the pitchfork mob should
always be stood against so that's the
first thing the second thing is you know
I don't know I this this manager the
Philadelphia location she doesn't work
there anymore I guess she got fired the
manager at law in the Los Angeles
location maybe they're racist I I don't
know I can't I don't know them
personally I can't say for sure they
aren't but there's that there are quite
a few reasons to suspect that there are
probably other explanations and what we
should do if we are rational and honest
people and we're you know and we're
decent people as well then we're not
going to immediately assume when
something like this happens we're not
going to immediately assume oh well it
must be racism we're not just going to
leapfrog over all of the other possible
explanations and say nope it's none of
them it's got to be racism so what are
some other possible explanations well we
know in the case
the case of Philadelphia let's take them
one at a time Philadelphia the two men
were sitting in the store taking up
seats they hadn't actually purchased
anything this is loitering it's
trespassing the these restaurants do not
exist
as just public forums - for you to just
come in and hang out anytime you want it
they own it they set the rules for
engagement and their rules for
engagement are I think pretty reasonable
pretty clear pretty simple you got to
buy something if you want to sit at the
table because there are a lot of here's
what happens there are a lot of
customers who do buy something and they
would like to have a table to sit at
but you're taking up the table even
though you didn't buy anything and
that's not fair and so that's why these
companies have rules against it now it
just so happens that this particular
location in Philadelphia has had
apparently a problem with loitering
recently and so this has been a policy
that they've been focusing on more and
more and they've had to enforce so the
store employees tried to deal with the
situation calmly and peacefully and
reasonably and they told the men that
look you know if you're not gonna buy
anything then you have to leave the two
guys refused to leave they refused to
leave the store okay even though they
were told you got to buy something or
leave
they said apparently they said we're not
gonna buy anything and we're not gonna
leave either and then the employee said
okay well then we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna call the police and
apparently what the two men said was
we'll go ahead and calm it we're still
not gonna leave then the police arrived
and they're negotiating with these men
for several minutes and saying look you
just need to leave you can't it's not
it's private property you can't just
hang out here if you're not a customer
and they still refused to leave so let's
go let's go through the let's go through
the process here okay step one we have
them deciding not to buy anything and
take up a table
- even when they're told well if you're
not gonna buy anything you got to leave
they still refuse to leave step 3 the
police show up and say well you got to
leave and they still refused so then
they got arrest now of course it's in
its claim that the white Pete that it's
claimed that well you know white people
loiter at Starbucks all the time and
they're never asked to leave really I
mean do you know that that's quite a
thing to just declare well white white
people are never told to leave Starbucks
how do you know you're you're telling me
it never happens you know that for a
fact you know that a dislocation in
Philadelphia they have never asked white
people to leave for loitering do you
know that because if you know it I mean
let please provide your evidence because
that would be very significant I mean if
you had evidence that they frequently
allow white people to loiter and never
enforce the rules against white people
but then they do against black people
well then that is compelling evidence of
racial discrimination and then the
protests are warranted in fact the
protest wouldn't even be warranted even
in that case because it's that would
still just be one manager who's now
fired who's guilty but at least they'd
be more warranted than they are now so
if you have evidence of that then let me
know I can tell you that I have I just
told you I have seen myself at a
Starbucks a white person being kicked
out for loitering so I know it does
happen and I'm betting it's happen at
this Philadelphia location because
that's see that's the thing if let's say
this manager whoever this person is is
just uncontrollably uncontainable racist
I mean they're so racist that they would
just that they would actually kick out
two black men simply for being black I
mean that is that's not just racist that
is that's like racism on steroids that
is you're so racist that you're gonna
even give up your job because that's
what you're doing that's what the
manager will be doing in that case the
manager is saying you know I'm gonna
forfeit this job just so I can make a
racist statement against these black men
which is possible but then the question
is how did this manager manage to
survive and function at a Starbucks in
Philadelphia if there's that racist
against black people because I would
assume and I'm just assuming but I think
it's pretty safe assumption that this
Starbucks in Philadelphia we're not
talking about a Starbucks in the middle
of a you know a town of 500 in North
Dakota
okay Starbucks in Philadelphia they
probably have black customers coming in
and out of that store hundreds of times
a week if not a day
and so has this manager I mean has she
is it does she always do this if she's
so racist against black people why is
this the first time she's kicked out
black people when there's been so many
others she could have kicked out and she
didn't it just it just doesn't make a
lot of sense
it's possible it just doesn't make a lot
of sense now then we have the incident
in Los Angeles now that that one to me
is even less of a may not one to me is
so clearly it's very clear that the guy
came in looking for he want that's why
he pulled out the video it's not a
normal if you're just innocently there
and you just want to use the bathroom
and someone tells you okay well you know
you got to buy something to use the
bathroom if your response is to pull out
a camera and start taking a video for
Twitter that means that this is what you
were looking for
okay this is not this one this wasn't an
innocent request in your part you were
looking for this exact response so that
you could try to entrap them in some
fake false racism claim but if the
question is well okay well why today
they said they they said no to the black
guy but the white guy was allowed to to
use the bathroom even though he didn't
buy anything you know must be racism
could be or you know there are other
explanations it's possible that the
white guy is a regular customer he's
there all the time they know him they
know that he's gonna buy something so
they let him use the bathroom first I
mean to me as just a logical person that
would be my first assumption I would
think it's probably that because regular
customers frequently get privileges that
non regular customers don't get I have
several coffee shops that I go through
all the time and they'll have my order
ready for me before I even get up to the
debt to that to the counter I get free
refills okay I get all this stuff
because I'm there all the time
I'm practically keeping them in business
on my own so could that be the
explanation should we at least consider
that explanation before we leap right -
oh it must be racism it must be that
this non-white woman working at a
Starbucks in in Los Angeles harbors this
grudge against black people I mean it
again possible but given the context in
the situation that would not even be
close to my first assumption so of
course everything I'm saying
it doesn't matter because I can't you
know you can't calm down the mob and and
these employees they don't even have
their CEO behind them so it's just it's
a done deal but we do have to consider
and think about I mean what's the
what's the implication here because now
what Starbucks has done now is they have
now announced that you're allowed to
loiter in their stores it's this is what
the CEO by apologizing profusely on
behalf of a manager who was simply
enforcing rules against loitering by
doing that what he has declared to
everybody in America is well at least if
you're not white you're allowed to
loiter I mean come on in use the Wi-Fi
sit down and use the bathrooms you don't
have to buy anything in fact bring your
own pack lunch bring up bring your own
dinner spread and just you know just sit
out and bring the family and just set up
you it set up a set up a blanket there
on the ground and have a picnic
basically what they've announced they
can't enforce rules against loitering
anymore there's a reason why I I when it
comes to situations like this I tend
very often to fall on the side of the
private company
I'll tell you something I felt the same
I was saying the same thing with that
with the whole controversy with whatever
airline it was I'm forgetting which
airline was or where they dragged the
guy out because he wouldn't give up his
seat and I sided with the airline on
that
you know why because even if it's an
unfair policy when you're sitting in
their establishment or in their airplane
and they tell you to leave you have to
leave they own it you don't you can't
exercise some right over and above their
own right to their own property
it's a very dangerous game we start
playing when we tell people that you now
have a human right to just march into a
private establishment and just stay
there even if they tell you to leave
even if the police tell you to leave you
don't have to know I I think that that
said that the implications are very
dangerous so most of the time I'm gonna
tend to side with the private company
whether the policy is fair or not at the
end of the day they it's their business
it's their building it's their plane
they exercise authority over it and you
have to play by their rules if you want
to use their property this to me is just
is just a basic rule of living in a free
and decent and civilized society
but we live in such a society less and
less I suppose so
there it is there's my contrarian take
on the Starbucks situation thanks for
watching thanks for listening everybody
I'll talk to you tomorrow